thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday November the
3rd
2022. my name is Freddie gray I am the
deputy editor of The Spectator and I
will be your host
today
coming up on the show we're going to be
talking about the migrant crisis which
is the big story of the week I'll be
joined by Patrick o Flynn who wrote this
week's cover piece in The Spectator on
the subject and our very own data nerd
Michael Simmons next we will move on to
politics to talk about which is sunak's
first few days as prime minister with
our politics team of James Forsyth and
Katie Bulls we will then cross the
Atlantic to talk to Bridget for tazy
about the midterm elections which are
coming up on Tuesday night
after that we will start to talk about
Twitter which has just been taken over
by Elon Musk and his plan to turn it
into something similar to WeChat which
is uh the everything app in China I'll
be talking to Cindy you our broadcast
editor about WeChat and what might
happen to Twitter
and finally we will talk to Stanley
Johnson a victim or survivor of the
celebrity jungle about Matt Hancock's
interesting decision to throw himself
into reality TV and appear on the show
I'm a celebrity get me out of here why
not subscribe to our YouTube channel you
can do that by clicking the red button
at the bottom of your screen and then
after that click the Subscribe button at
the top of your screen to make sure you
never miss an episode
let's start with the migrant crisis
which is the big story of the week there
have been 40 000 new arrivals in Britain
this year which is an unprecedented High
um it is the subject of our cover piece
this week uh at Sea can sunac navigate
the migrant crisis that piece was
written by Patrick o'flynn who's sitting
right here and I'm joined also by
Michael Simmons who's our data expert I
called you a data nerd in the intross
you can still be in there
um but Patrick I'll start with you
um the Tory party has known uh that this
is an issue that concerns voters they
have tried to address it for a very long
time they seem to have failed to address
it what is it about the Tory box if you
think that they begs them incapable of
addressing an issue that they know is
important to their voters
I think to be fair to them it's
difficult the the responses that would
work are liable to get a lot of blowback
from the liberal establishment which you
know they're they're Keen to sort of
keep one foot in and from International
bodies and from important other
countries uh so they have made the
fundamental mistake they've made uh is
to over promise on the basis of policies
which obviously won't work so Boris
Johnson when he first became prime
minister and this issue of the dinghies
had just started uh said we will send
you back and that was a an absolute Rock
Solid place from Boris looking down the
lens of a camera on national news uh and
it never happened and then you you also
had pretty Patel as a Home Secretary who
constantly over claimed and
over-promised and under delivered I
remember her at the um October 2021 Tory
conference saying triumphantly she was
break the model of the people
traffickers or she obviously wasn't uh
you know Michael will confirm from the
the data that she wasn't it was getting
worse every year and has continued to
get worse the thing that that could
solve it the sort of policies that could
solve it might involve coming out all
together from the jurisdiction of the
European Court of Human Rights uh well
probably not the the Rwanda scheme if it
gets off the ground won't be sufficient
we will need to have standard offshore
processing uh from anyone who arrives
legally at a British overseas territory
something quite dramatic and if this had
been done three years ago it could have
been done at quite a small scale and it
would have nipped the problem in the
butt but now it's going to need a big
facility to be built and it's going to
cause a lot of blowback as I said soon
it would be for instance accused of
flouting terms of the EU withdrawal
agreement in respect to the echr some
people would say the same of the Good
Friday agreement so they've got
themselves into a position where it's
become very court but the salience of
the issue among their key Target groups
of boaters is huge they're the 2019
Tories the leave voters that they need
in order just to be competitive at the
next election there was a sense uh
wasn't there in the Johnson years that
uh both Boris Johnson and pretty Patel
were quite willing to court the public
row to get the negative headlines
because that got focused on side because
photos actually quite like a government
that's tough on the migrant crisis but
they weren't actually willing to address
it do you think Rishi sunak is more
likely to address it while being
slightly more nervous perhaps himself
about the headlines
um I think Russia shunax something of a
mystery he could be the proverbial wolf
in sheep's clothing he looks a very
conventional uh prime minister from the
sort of Blair Cameron type of uh uh of
image and and and approach but I think
he is intelligent enough to know that
he's in a really tricky spot here he
also he doesn't have someone like pretty
patellas is homosexual who ultimately
was wholly subservient Boris Johnson he
has someone that I regard as you know
not the most articulate uh Home
Secretary in suela braveman but a bit of
a political killer she was a brexit
Spartan who effectively helped kill
Theresa May she's just done a deal with
with Rishi soon act that killed Boris
Johnson and if he's not careful she
might kill him she has enormous support
on the Tory right and among red wall MPS
who actually turned out for her in the
Commons on Monday in very large numbers
and I think she's already putting the
prime minister under far more direct
pressure to help her take the sort of
steps that has a chance succeeding than
pretty Patel ever did to Boris Johnson
Michael give us some of the data just we
get thrown a lot of figures about how
bad things are getting give us some of
the more Salient figures that you've
noticed so as Patrick mentioned and
we're above M40 000 now in the Small
Boat Crossings and that's kind of the
really the big kind of headline headline
grab and figure and but what is kind of
hidden is really the real strain that
our Asylum application system is under
at the moment so as it stands at the
moment there's about 127 000 Asylum
Seekers and their dependents who are
waiting uh for their um applications to
be processed and what's really
interesting about that figure is 10
years ago that number was only about 15
000 but today 15 000 are just in
Albanian Nationals and that equates to
about roughly one in every 180 um like
people in the the Albanian population if
you restrict that just to men it's more
like one in a hundred and obviously most
of the people that are coming over and
from Albania are tending to be sort of
um young men in terms of how long these
um applications are um kind of taking to
process as well it's looking on average
now about 500 Days and of course during
this time and for most of it the Asylum
figures are not allowed to work they're
not even allowed to do voluntary stuff
early on and so for all that time you
know there's literally hundreds of
thousands of people and are just in
British towns and cities with nothing
kind of nothing to do and at the same
time we've seen uh the the amount in six
months and it started about 87 were
processed within that time now it's
nearer six percent so that just shows
the system has just you know complete
almost completely collapsed at the same
time though the grant rate has kind of
shot up so now if you are an asylum
Seeker eventually you are more likely to
um kind of be have a successful
application and the removals rate has
gone down quite significantly yeah the
removals rate um has kind of really
um gone down through the floor but that
that kind of started
um kind of over the last decade and kind
of hasn't really been a recent thing and
that's kind of because there's been more
and more success with legal challenges
and appeals
um and that maybe not so much a recent
problem but it's it's something that's
built up over time and now that the kind
of raw numbers of people coming is so
big that it's just that's kind of what's
brought the system almost to a halt it's
an old Paradox isn't it Patrick as the
public conversation and indeed the
political composition has got much
tougher about uh immigration uh the
system seems to be getting softer and
softer yes and I think that's also true
of legal migration routes where you know
under the radar Boris Johnson you know
ran a very liberal uh uh um regime you
know and and you know I think the the
figure philosophy was a million visas
issued for for long-term residents in
the UK the highest level uh ever and
then we also have Boris uh you know
signing some pretty generous open-ended
undertakings in respect for instance of
uh ukrainians in respect of Hong Kong uh
British national overseas passport
holders uh he announced a completely
unilateral uh open-ended uh undertaking
that Britain would take everybody you
know he didn't even get together with
Canada Australia New Zealand and say
come on chat you've got more room than
us can we put together an offer here
given the Chinese government's
increasing oppression so you know this
this issue with the illegal arrivals
cynically gaming the system coming
across on dinghies is in that wider
context where I think the the anxiety
about the approach to immigration
overall is is on a rising path again
there's a feeling that we have a housing
stock which can't cope for the number of
people already here our public services
are under pressure and that we haven't
really got our integration strategy
right for instance the the recent um
unfortunate events in Leicester being an
example of that that hang on are we sure
with everyone who's come from all
different parts of the world that we
we've yet had enough time for people to
get to know each other and work out you
know what's uh laudable diversity and
celebrating Heritage and what's core
common culture that everyone should sign
up to so I think the Public's very
anxious about that as well the Express
on the front page reporting about the
government has the Rwandan scheme is
going to be actually extended or
expanded to include other countries Peru
Paraguay and Belize I think and another
African country as yet undisclosed
um I mean the random scheme hasn't
really worked yet has it no anyone can
pretend that it has
um but I suppose the thinking maybe that
Paraguay and Peru are not as politically
sort of incendiary as Rwanda as a
country to send violence to well you
know it it is interesting isn't it that
that the government would would increase
the number of countries for a scheme
that hasn't even worked in what would be
the pilot scheme right that that to me
uh relying on other countries to address
your own you know problems with illegal
immigration it always puts you at risk
of the country's regime changing and
them saying we don't want to do this
anymore and when Britain has its own
overseas territories a more secure path
would be that we would take
responsibility for our own issues and
have a basically uh
um
as a resilient approach that wouldn't
collapse but I suppose if we can bring
other countries on scheme that spreads
the risk and and spreads the load I'm
very skeptical and I'm sure most voters
will be given that not a single migrant
has has gone to Rwanda uh whether
there's much point at this moment
pressing ahead with with other partner
countries too what is the solution and
because in your piece you suggest a new
convention uh between uh European States
including Britain on
um the treatment of migrants well I
think that's worth exploring because I
think there's high anxiety among the
conventional European governing
political parties that they're getting
out flanked uh the public opinion is is
not happy the result of merkel's you
know everyone come you know I think even
she would recognize as a mistake and has
caused all kinds of integration problems
social cohesion problems and there are
you know populist right right-wing
parties making progress in many European
countries now so the appetite for a new
approach uh that that is not so
open-ended is certainly there but I
personally see uh the solution for
Britain is to uh create within its own
uh domains and unilaterally a resilient
program like the Australians did 15
years ago which would involve standard
processing offshore in a British
overseas territory and a general
principle that no one who arrives
illegally gets long-term residents in
Britain even if they're Asylum claim
itself is validated they would be then
found another country another safe
country to be resettled in and this was
an approach that the think tank policy
exchange recommended in a paper I would
commend to people to have a look at
earlier this year
do you think there's a case for a new
possibly bigger government Department to
deal specifically with this because
there's a lot of resentment about the
home office and a feeling that the home
office just hasn't been able to deal
with this issue we stories today about
migrants being left outside in their
flip-flops for hours uh waiting for
buses because the the logistical
facilities aren't there yeah they're
certainly you know and has been for
years a strong case to break the home
office in too so you would have a sort
of Law and Order and policing department
and an immigration and Asylum Department
that sounds like an organizational fix
and it seems to me that a lot of home
office uh senior officials are not a
verse to undermining home secretaries
who are trying to implement an agenda
that the home office doesn't regard as
quote home office policy the classics a
Humphrey thing now whether it would
actually work I don't know I mean I
don't think creating new departments is
a Panacea you know but it would seem to
offer more accountability on the issue
of immigration and Asylum if you had an
important Standalone White Hall Ministry
with a secretary of state specifically
in charge of that area
Michael you mentioned uh albanians the
Albanian government today has reviews
Britain for being rude about being
saying they're all criminals and so on
uh give us the actual moral on the
actual data of that I mean a lot of them
don't do but seem to belong to criminal
gangs and our smuggles into the country
to carry out crimes is there any hard
good data on that and well this is is
kind of part of the problem is that
we're we're really in a sort of
um kind of blank kind of dark space
about knowing what actually Asylum
Seekers are doing while they're here
because because the fact they're not
allowed to work but obviously we all
know a lot of them do work because it's
something that's officially not allowed
to happen it's not really kind of being
monitored and so kind of the answer to
your question is no and that's kind of a
huge part of the problem that you know
we don't know in some cases we don't
even know where in the country kind of
people end up but obviously if people
leave official services and they're not
in like the the centers that are set up
for them then they're obviously doing
something to make a and make a living
and that some of that will be crying
others will be just be illegal
employment where they are being
exploited because you know that's a way
that people can pay people less than the
minimum wage so in a way the only data
that you can pick them up on is is
through crime is yeah
um and then it's kind of all it's just
speculation of amounts who's kind of
arrived I think it's worth saying here
by the way that Teresa Mays modern
slavery legislation has become an
example of the Road to Hell being paved
with good intentions because uh we've
got to have the Absurd situation where
uh many uh Albanian arrivals are putting
forward the argument I was brought here
against my will therefore you must let
me stay which is an odd idea but I'm
making use of the idea of of being
trafficked and in some cases
particularly in case cases of young
women I'm sure genuinely so but why the
just outcome to someone being brought to
the United Kingdom against their will is
to say you therefore stay in the to
Kingdom that seems to me rather
illogical Theresa May was prayed quite a
lot for being such a long-serving Home
Secretary and in a job that often has
had quite a high turnover her Legacy
doesn't look so good now is what you're
saying uh no I think it's fair to say
Theresa May's Legacy doesn't look so
good I think a lot of viewers will agree
uh Michael Patrick thank you very much
indeed thank you
now let's look at what's going on in
Westminster this week I am joined by our
politics editors James Forsyth and Katie
Bulls uh James let's start with you we
just had Patrick o'flynn talking about
his cover piece about the migrant crisis
and he suggested that Rishi sunak could
be a wolf in sheep's clothing because he
has a sort of nice uh soft image that uh
liberal people on immigration tend to
like and yet he could be the Prime
Minister that finally does get tough on
this very very emotive issue so I think
the small boats is turning into a kind
of competence test for the government uh
I think that you know when Santa Javed
came back from his Christmas holiday
remember the numbers were were
relatively small the numbers have now
increased dramatically uh more people
crossed in a single day like one one
single day last week than crossing the
first six or seven months of 2019 put
together and so I think the government
now does have to come up with it with a
solution to the problem or at least a
plan that says that they know how they
intend to deal with this
and I think that that is that is
something that you know this isn't also
kind of I think previously you could say
that the government were raising the
savings for small boats issue by talking
tough about an issue that and they're
not delivering on it I think now the
problem has become such that the
government has no choice but to deliver
on it and it's and tough rhetoric of the
kind of type as well a rather than has
been using that alone is not going to
cut the master you are going to have to
show that you are making progress on
dealing with this and and particularly
what is driving the the the the current
dramatic increase in numbers and is
there uh there's been a lot of talk
about will sort of turn onto a brothman
are they singing from the same hymn
sheet uh is she
um sort of embarrassing annoying him by
maneuvering like this on no I think she
is home secretary because there was a
belief that you needed a cabinet that
was kind of bounced across the Tory of
actions
and because you know she is you know
serious about dealing with this issue
and I think that you know the the the
the they have to deal with this the idea
that you can say oh we're going to have
you know it's for the birds the the
government
it the government is committed on this
course and now has to deliver on it
Casey uh moving on to other topics Rishi
sunak uh you turned we had we had a
first uh Richardson at U-turn this week
on cop uh why did that happen yes I
think this is the first proper U-turn
since originally entered number ten
someone said oh it's actually number
seven or number eight and depending how
you count it but I think the
significance here is that on entering
number 10 Downing Street suggested that
he would not be going to cop 27 in Egypt
instead of be focusing on the Autumn
statement and then this week uh he said
that he would be going after all and
that came after criticism not just from
the opposition but from some on the Tory
side so Boris Johnson saying he would go
I'm sure didn't go unnoticed in number
10. um but also the cop president Alex
Sharma saying Rishi ceiling should go
and therefore the question is is this uh
a gesture that shows which you see like
as a listening mode and is willing to
own up to mistakes or uh you know change
course if you think that's the right
thing or does it just show that when and
faced with enough pressure British
pseudical switch direction in which case
what does that mean for what's to come
with you know tricky starts in the
Autumn statement and so forth do you
think that the importance of Boris
Johnson telling does that mean slightly
exaggerated by a press that's in the
mood to be to make that comparison so
that these two men hate each other so
much and they're in competition yeah I
mean I think we're so used at this point
I think we're so used to at this point
Tori's psychodrama that you know people
are looking at lots of ways I think that
Boris Johnson using them into his guide
to say that he had realized cop 26 have
become a bit unfashionable in parts of
the party and does suggest there's still
like enough
um jives going around about um you know
his successor and what Tori Kansas said
about his legacy on the environment
um so I think on on this utahn I mean
the I think ultimately it's just too
early to tell if this is significant is
this a sign of Richard Cena's nature is
it the fact that they came in didn't
expect to be a number 10 this quickly
after the implosion of Liz trust's
government and spent the first week
almost Flying Blind with lots of things
and made this quick decision and no
change course
um I think ultimately there was an
argument that with the Autumn statement
you would have
a situation whereby the decisions are
going to be so unpalatable having the
Prime Minister flying to this event you
know in a fancy hotel like well leaders
could actually seem to detached from
reality well let's see what they
announce
um later this month and how it lands
James
another figure in this story that's
whose feature called is King Charles uh
who seems to have or certainly the
palace has certainly been putting it
about that he was not happy uh being
told by Liz trust that he shouldn't
attend uh being advised by the distrust
station intent and that uh it's it felt
like a bit of pressure was being applied
on soon act to change that policy but
actually it turns out it would have been
too late anyway and King Charles wasn't
going to go yeah it's an interesting
story in Thursday's times which says
essentially that
you know Richie tonight was not you know
didn't was not gonna inclined to keep
the bar on Prince Charles going that
existed beforehand but it just simply
turned out to be too late to go for
Charles to go in terms of the logistics
and King Charles was having this event
at the palace on Friday which is a kind
of road to cop event where John Kerry
who is you know uh I've been close to
King Charles on these climate issues and
Richardson Alex Sharma and all these
various Business Leaders will be there I
think there is a I mean there is there
is there is going to be a fascinating
question about how King Charles does you
know the things that were at that he did
as Prince of Wales were his great causes
how did he carry on doing those as king
yeah and then there is also I think uh a
delicate question about how he balances
the fact that he is not just uh King of
the United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland but also a whole bunch
of other countries I think one of the
things that was that one of the things
that those who favored King Charles
going was saying was hang on a second
some of these smaller commonwealth
countries are really on the front line
when it comes to climate change and they
would like him there so why is the
British government
saying that you know that their head of
state can't be there so I think it is a
reminder of some of the challenges but
uh that are that are coming up in terms
of because you know obviously with uh
the queens that you know in various
places you have reopened some of these
debates about their constitutional
Arrangements I think he's going to
require some very careful footwork from
both the palace and the UK government to
handle these questions that would be
very interesting to see let's move on to
uh windfall tax uh every labor idea
becomes a Tory policy eventually is that
fair for me to say that well I think
briefly under Liz trust the team that
might cease to be the case but then of
course that didn't end particularly well
um so now we're back on uh the train
which is liquid Rachel Reves and Ed
Miller Band are saying and uh expected
to come to a katori government near you
um but yes this is um when it comes to
the Autumn uh statement we know that the
treasury are very much along with number
10 trying to lower expectations for this
50 billion fiscal black hole and say
that's going to be tax Rises for
everyone there's going to be spending
cuts and one aspect of this we expect to
also be an increased or you know uh
windfall tax when it comes to the energy
companies now Richard Cena brought us in
when he was Chancellor at the time there
are figures in Downing Street who really
fought the original windfall tax that it
was unconservative that was certainly
less trusted for you too and but the
view of those around where she's Scenic
was it pulls really well
um it is probably one of the most
popular things you can do when it comes
to revenue raises and therefore is there
an argument for going further this time
around it seems there is one of the
options one of the things they are
likely to bring forward I think the
question is which you see next view has
been that the way you get growth is
through private investment so with the
original info tax ultimately you could
avoid much of the tax if you uh show
that you're investing in the long term
and therefore we're expecting uh well
this to be extended but also increased
in terms of the percentage of the
windfall tax but how does this go
alongside the the growth incentives
because if they're trying to bring in
money to fill the fiscal black hole
actually you want what would you want
for that to be achieved as people
actually just paying straight up and and
therefore I think in terms of Landing
this other question is how does the
right of the party respond to this
because they didn't like the first one
and they're going to like a revamp
probably not but the whole I think the
big test of this Autumn statement is
effectively a situation whereby various
parts of the party are going to have to
swallow things they don't like and the
question is in terms of tour Unity we
have an uneasy truce at the moment where
I think everyone has decided to behave
at least for a few weeks and if you do
have things that you know foreign aid
not um you know not being increased in
the race and want it and you know being
delayed if you have defense spending
actually not going up in the way that
some campaign for as Ben Wallace has
said he wants and if you have a windfall
tax and also personal tax Rises do MPS
throw their toys at the prom or actually
do people say this is what we need for
difficult times because I think as soon
as one faction starts to say I don't
like this and that's when discipline
will probably break down across the
whole party James it's not a windfall
tax in name only it's not just a
headline grabbing thing that actually
won't raise that much revenue but it it
gets the right headlines on site it gets
the right story across for the Prime
Minister oh yeah I think it raises some
money I mean there is a you know I mean
there is an intellectual justification
for it which is these extraordinary
profits have not been triggered by any
great innovation in the energy sector
they are essentially wartime profits
because of what Houston's invasion of
Ukraine has done to Global Energy prices
I mean there is also a big question
about how how the the original windfall
tax basically to set a level average of
energy prices remained above that level
the windfall tax would apply I mean
there is it there is there is an
intriguing question as to how long we
expect Energy prices to remain elevated
we know that the treasury think they
will remain elevated in historical times
for the rest of this decade you know
um will they will they put in a line as
they did in the original windfall tax
and if Energy prices drop back below
this historic level then the windfall
tax but we'll see so I mean that's that
is along with the investment incentives
that is something to watch and then I
think the other thing to watch is how
does this extend to uh electricity
generators of Renewables you know they
are also getting a huge bump in how much
they're paying now not all of them are
because some of them are in these things
will contract the difference which
essentially sets the price which means
they can't be paid more than that price
but you know how do you handle that
question and then there is a whole
bigger argument the the the the the that
we've discussed in the past on you know
what is your energy security mix what do
you think gives you greater protection
against the kind of price movements that
we've seen uh in in in in VCR with the
following the Russian invasion of the
Ukraine speaking of that um you did
touch on this Katie but uh Ben Wallace
it seems to be in negotiation at the
moment over uh spending possible
spending cuts to defense uh what's going
to happen there well I think you can see
Ben Wallace always softening a little
bit in some of his public statements on
this now this all relates to a pledge
that Richardson did not make is a Liz
truss pledge when it came to increasing
defense spending to three percent of GDP
by 2030 and you have a situation whereby
Ben Wallace and James heapey defense
minister and the Liz truss went out and
the airwaves during her brief
Premiership and said he would resign if
this did not go up in the way he
expected it to now I think it's
significant that Richard has not was
named at this but also when there was
some discussion about his cabinet and
Ben Wallace or at least a journalist
that had been known that Ben Wallace was
no longer at the view that he would quit
the cabinet or not be able to serve in
it it had this does this not meet the
exact timeline he wanted and so I think
the the question so it does feel as
though defense is one area where it's
not so much
um new cats but potentially the speed of
investment compared to expectations just
a few weeks ago
um could be in two different places but
I think if you look at some of them
honest comments earlier this week it
feels at least there is a landing space
and again you look at that reshuffle Ben
Wallace Andrew Mitchell who led the
foreign aid Rebellion now and now in the
foreign office
um you have Rob Halford who's known
education Minister that could be cuts to
education and I think there is an effort
Hugh Merriman uh former chair of the
transport select committee he's been
very critical in some of the
government's plans and they effectively
have brought lots of potential Rebels if
you ask me to write a list of the people
who would Rebel about various issues a
lot of them are actually in the
government and so they effort doesn't
work to the point that they will front
these changes in difficult times and
bring the you know MPS on side or does
it all go wrong and you get quite a few
resignations so more psycho dramas
Before Christmas do you think well I
think there's a potential for it I think
the test is if you can get through this
Autumn statement without any
resignations and just a few grumbas on
the back benches I think that is the
clearest sign yet that the Tory party
does want to govern and actually Camp is
like a drama behind it I think if it all
starts to implode after that I think
people will conclude this an
ungovernable party very interesting
indeed thank you very much James and
Katie next week America will go to the
polls for the midterm elections and the
Republicans if the polls are correct
seem to be gaining quite a lot of ground
I'm joined Now by Bridget for tazy who
is a columnist for spectator world and a
brilliant podcaster and YouTuber and all
such stuff uh Bridget you think there's
going to be a red wave for the
Republicans do you not I think so so I
think it seems that way that definitely
seems to be the temperature it's you
know I I think it's hard with polls
because
who will pick up the phone to be pulled
and who will actually take a poll and
who's lying and
um but it does the temperature seems to
be
people are mad you know they see it as
kind of a retribution for
for the pandemic policies or mandates in
many cases and this is their way to
extract that vengeance
you think the pandemic is as big a
factor as the economy
I think the economy is a big one too I
mean I think that's a huge I think
that's a huge piece is that people are
worried about the economy things haven't
been great the shelves have been Barren
that gas has been really high there's
and then you have this residual
resentment that still seems to exist
that actually I think was really stoked
by the Atlantic piece about having a
pandemic amnesty it seemed to have the
opposite effect where it reminded people
of all the rage that they still have
for things that happen during during the
pandemic I saw that just for all uh
British listeners who may not have seen
that that was a piece in the Atlantic
saying uh we need to have an amnesty
about covert and forgive each other for
all the fights and arguments we had and
the reaction on social media was
enormous and it was to the effect of
hell no I think was the first summary of
what it was he
yeah I think you have to have
accountability before you you are asking
for forgiveness you have to admit that
things went wrong and
and I don't think that that's really
the case in this instance I don't think
anybody said oh maybe we did we didn't
do any a lot of these things right we
were doing the best we could
um even after we had more information we
could have made some changes earlier
that might have given people relief and
people are mad they they didn't people
died alone people kids last years of
their lives and I think that people are
rightfully still angry about a lot of
the things they felt they had no control
over like being forced into getting a
vaccine or keeping their job when there
wasn't very much scientific evidence to
back that up so there's definitely a
palpable anger and in blue States in
particular I'm in California it seems
like the the moms are mad well I saw a
piece today suggesting that Suburban
mothers are breaking towards Republicans
quite heavily uh in the days leading up
to what do you think that is and is our
actual sort of natural Democrats seem to
be embracing the idea of voting
Republican is that not going on
there does seem to be that for the first
time I mean you can't I know they want
to try and downplay crime you know that
they being the media or people saying oh
this is just people being hysterical but
I live in I have eyes I let people know
what they see with their own eyes and I
live in a blue city that has
progressively become more dangerous
there's more mental illness on every
single corner there's more encampments
everywhere I turn that's not something
I'm just imagining that's something I'm
seeing in real time and I don't think
I'm alone and I think that in blue
States in particular
the kids were locked down and out of
school for the some of the longest
periods of time now we're seeing the
learning delays a lot of the social
delays and this affects people I would
say the lower class is more affected by
this as well a lot of the people that we
claim you know the the liberal claim to
care about they suffered the greatest
people are poor people are not as hell
they're sicker and
so I don't think it's
um I don't think it's weird that people
are looking around and saying I I don't
know what to do but I know whatever I've
been doing is not working so just voting
for the opposite party seems like the
the move we should clarify that you
yourself you'll not pause and you are
politically homeless uh as you called
yourself in a brilliant spectator
article
um uh I mean do you think a lot of
Americans are like you they are they are
without a political tribe uh but they're
extremely Fed Up frustrated and actually
just sort of weirded out by uh the
parties that represent them
I do I think it's tough you you know you
want to there doesn't seem to be a a
principled party although they might
both claim to have the kind of moral
High Ground
And I think that being kind of in the
Wasteland of the center as I call it I I
definitely am taking things more
uh like piecemeal you know it's more
instance by instance and and
I would say that in California it's just
a one-party state so I I'll vote just
read just for some kind of balance for
any kind of balance there's no balance
in California at all so I'm in a
different circumstance and for instance
somewhere in a purple state where my
vote might actually matter and
California it doesn't really matter but
I do think there's I mean we're seeing
such close races in places where it
shouldn't be close like in New York City
in Oregon they might have a governor for
the first time in 40 years who's
Republican Oregon I've anyone who knows
anything about Oregon this is like the
most blue hippie state but you've seen
the videos of what's gone on in Portland
over the years and people when when
people are worried about their safety I
think historically they just vote red
I'm I'm not a policy expert or political
expert but I believe that's usually the
trend
a lot of Democrats were quite excited
over the summer because they thought
they were getting a lot of momentum
after the Supreme Court overturned Roe v
Wade do you think they exaggerated uh
how much that meant the American public
uh or did that energy fade or is it now
fading
yeah that was interesting I think they
did get some momentum but I feel like
when they pull people it's like seventh
on the list of things that they are
concerned about I don't actually think
it's very high on the list uh when
you're faced with inflation and again
this is a thing that people want to
downplay but when you're somebody who
counts you know pennies and is working
within a budget you know that your money
isn't going as far you know that that
grocery bill that you get every single
week is not it's costing you more money
you know that the gas commute the gas
for the commute you do is costing you
more this isn't something you're just
imagining and it's even more offensive
when people
are telling you oh don't you're just
being crazy this is inflation isn't
really that bad and the prices aren't
going up and your dollar isn't worth as
much and everything is going up so
people are really feeling that and
that's
I'm sorry but crime and what things are
costing these are you know they affect
people
very personally you know instantly and
personally
it's not like that thing this Theory
over there one thing that strikes me
looking at it as a foreigner looking at
these elections is how odd some of the
Senate candidates are I mean you have
John FedEx who uh had a stroke and and
obviously that's very horrible for him
but it's just quite odd to watch him
carry on even though he clearly can't
talk properly uh campaigning and sort of
not nobody really admitting within his
camp that some things aren't right uh
then you have Herschel Walker who's a
sort of extraordinary character uh very
charismatic but with an extremely
colorful past
um you have Carrie Lake uh running for
governor as well who's who's quite a
telegenic uh and Loud character what's
going on it feels like Wacky Races to me
yeah they are wacky and I don't I don't
think that people are very happy about
the options you know the the average
person doesn't seem too excited it's
it's hard because you feel I feel like
this is the best we can do there's you
know hundreds of millions of people in
this country and these are the people
that were putting up to lead
and unfortunately I don't think that the
kind of people who want to get into
politics are the people who should be
getting into politics and the people who
should be have no interest in getting
into politics and with you know with
Fetter minutes it feels almost again it
almost feels like a slap in the face
like you're just supposed you know we
know you're gonna vote blue no matter
who who we put up there and it feels uh
it's it's like a weird sort of
entitlement that the the party has the
both parties have but in this instance
it's it seems like we know you're going
to vote for this person even though
they're they just had a stroke and have
a hard time talking and then if you note
that
you're somehow enableist or you're
you're somebody who doesn't care about
the disabled it also feels like um
politics uh people have said that
they're fed up with Politics as Usual
and so the American political system has
given people just very abnormal
politicians and that's not necessarily
what people wanted is it
no and yes I mean I guess we get the the
leaders we deserve isn't that the
expression you know I I know that people
wanted the change the the the wrecking
ball that was Trump people liked that he
came in and he and he exposed a lot of
I mean everything for on all sides for
everything that it is and now with Biden
it was I don't know if it was like this
sense of returning back to some normal
but it hasn't been normal at all it's
been strange and unsettling in a
different kind of way and then you have
like you said Herschel Walker and all
these people that it feels like people
are having to put aside their principles
because the culture war is so much more
important than whatever your principles
might be so okay he even if you're
pro-life and you find out that he paid
for an abortion Herschel Walker you're
still gonna vote for that person because
having control of the Senate is more
important than whatever your personal
principles might be in regards to that
that person who's running
and when you're doing that it's like I
mean of course you're gonna get
candidates who are weird if people are
just saying I don't my own principles be
damned I'm I'm it's all about power and
in in some respects it is
you sometimes in your writing and uh in
your broadcast you sound in a sort of
state of despair about America is that
getting worse uh over these midterms or
or are you actually beginning to find a
bit of Hope
um
you know I'm in despair
for different reasons more I'm more
concerned with everyone's mental health
and the addiction and the deaths of
Despair and
the trickle-down effect of a lot of
all of this Insanity you know the the
the div just how divided we are just
everybody's spending too much time
online the lack of Grace and compassion
that we have for one another we had Paul
Pelosi get attacked there's conspiracy
theories everywhere people don't trust
anything and I understand why and then
you have people laughing about it but
people on both sides do this when
there's political violence or sweep it
under the rug and that seems to be the
self-fulfilling prophecy that keeps on
escalating and I'm not I'm not sure
where the bottom is to that you know it
feels like
even in California it feels like
California needs to hit rock bottom
before it can kind of start recovering
but America feels that way too although
parts of it seem
like they're more behind other places
where it feels just a bit out of control
well there are still great Americans
Like You Bridget so thank you very much
thank you
Elon Musk the billionaire has bought
Twitter you may have noticed and there's
been a lot of complaining and worrying
about what he might do to the app but he
has made his intentions quite clear he
said he wants it to be an everything app
and the model the inspiration for it it
seems is the Chinese app WeChat uh which
Cindy you our broadcast editor is here
to explain to us a bit about WeChat in
China Cindy is a kind of uh everything
app you can do everything through it is
that right can you tell us a little bit
about what it's like how it works yeah
so WeChat really is an everything app so
it started a simple messaging platform
so you might imagine WhatsApp or
something like that but since then it
added this wallet functions WeChat pay
so you might think of your Apple pay on
your phone imagine that's added to your
WhatsApp app so which means that you can
send money to your family and friends
but also you can pay for services and so
if you have an integrated deliveroo food
ordering app on this on WeChat which you
do you can pay through that so you can
do everything from food ordering to
ordering taxis to getting making
doctor's appointments buying train
tickets anything and everything you can
think of as long as the service is out
there to do it that business can launch
themselves onto each chat because WeChat
allows you to build these kind of sub
software so what's the Chinese recording
of uber then what's so that's there's
one called which is yeah which on WeChat
yeah and you can have like an interface
on WeChat for that you can also also use
Diddy's own app but what WeChat does is
that because everything is integrated
all together they're making it so that
you never have to leave and obviously
some people still use multiple apps and
many people do do that but it's about
the ease of the thing it's about how
convenient it is to never have to leave
this one app and they are really
dominating the market with that and it
uses the currency as Yen there's no
there's no coin that you use on no
there's no crypto involved because
there's been a lot of speculation of the
route musk that he's going Dogecoin has
rallied massively in the last few days
because people think he might use Doge
as a payment system I mean part of the
problem is that WETA has to very much
follow Chinese laws and cryptocurrencies
are fans in China yeah they're not fans
of it um China's trying to roll out its
own digital currency
um and WeChat is trying to integrate
that as well but no the the currency is
remain B so you link it to your Chinese
bank card you add money into it or you
get money from your family and friends
and then you can basically use it as a
bank card okay and the the owner of
WeChat is uh pangmar Pony
but anything is his given name I think
he chose it but yeah Pony ma no relation
of Jack ma no relation Jack ma but both
of them are the leading Cutting Edge of
basically Chinese Silicon Valley but
Jack Ma has fallen foul of uh the
People's Republic whereas uh Pony is
still in favor
various kind of um Anti-Trust
regulations uh fines running up to kind
of billions of dollars we're talking
about have really kind of Taken these um
companies down a peg they're losing uh
Talent they're losing people that they
were hiring at a really fast pace before
Jack ma was a special case because he
was just so out there you know he was so
um he's such a tall poppy with the
things that he would do you know who do
who do these concerts for his
um employees dress up like Michael
Jackson he would commentate on what he
thinks Chinese politics is like you know
you don't you don't do that kind of
stuff if you want to succeed in China
there's too much public personality for
the for the CCP exactly and pony pony
takes a much lower profile with that and
but even he has you know his company is
10 cent runs video games so people might
know them from League of Legends unless
the company behind that uh they've been
taken down a peg by government
regulation against video games then we
chats the other Big Arm office company
um and that so far is okay
um well it's interesting is it because
10 cent uh obviously are possible to the
the Chinese Communist party and they
they have to obey when they're told to
do things but in a more liberal Society
like America Twitter if Twitter does
turn into an everything app and has the
kind of power that WeChat has uh it
can't really be answerable to the
government I mean it could be it you
know people talk about big Tech becoming
more powerful WeChat in a in a free
Society could be even more powerful than
it already is I think yeah I think
that's true and also under I mean I
think big Tech in the west has already
signaled to governments that they want
to cooperate right with their Online
safety Bill Twitter and YouTube are
saying to governments leave it to us
we'll self-regulate all of this kind of
stuff and I think it really depends on
what the government does with that you
know is this legal but harmful Clause is
that going to be kept in there
um which would give a lot of these tech
companies the right to arbitrate what
can and can't be said but even leaving
that aside
um they have a lot of data they do have
a lot of data but I think being a free
Society will be much harder to create a
WeChat equivalent because there's just
so much competition you know WeChat
developed in a country behind the great
firewall you know there was no Facebook
there was no WhatsApp there was no
YouTube and so there was very little
external competition obviously the
Chinese social media apps scrapped
between each other's like anything but
that obviously does help
um so I think I think Elon Musk will
have a tough job on his hands to really
try to incorporate all of that into one
because I can't see why if your delivery
would let him get away with that or if
you're uber or any of these other apps
why you would want to lose your own
Market stake finally you've written a
very interesting piece about this in
this week's spectator and uh you talk
about these red envelopes so when you
send money on WeChat it arrives in a red
envelope yes
this is a Chinese custom giving people
money stuffed stuffing money in red
envelopes and giving it to them that and
that's a custom going back to the to
where thousands of years yeah and you
remember it from your childhood yeah
yeah I do and it's a lovely thing to do
it's a bit like um how how your parents
might feel your stocking over Christmas
Eve
parents fill their kids read one
balloons put it under their pillows over
Chinese New Year Eve because the idea is
that it Wards off evil and it Wards off
the children's story goes there Wards of
a monster which comes and grabs kids and
it's scared of the red and I love that I
love that part of Chinese culture but
I've not received those in years not
because I've grown up but because have
you received a red wallet on WeChat yes
all the time yeah all the time yeah um
it's great because being overseas for
the first few years I was here I was
really losing out on a lot of money
because my family in China couldn't give
me any physical money yeah so now I'm
now getting that money but at the same
time
um the Romance of the thing the
tradition of the thing cash itself is
obsolete in China in a lot of urban
China at least yes
um well that's I mean do Chinese people
regret that because what limited Freedom
they have in China is is partly enabled
by cash and a cashless Society is a less
free Society do not think yeah
absolutely and that's why the government
wants to create this digital currency to
go alongside proper cash so that they
basically can see every one's
transactions if they wanted to
um I think there's a lot of data that
you give away through using this free
app that because social media came in
such a storm in China and everyone kind
of wanted to get onto it and it became
such a popular thing to get on I write
in my piece that it would be possible to
live without WeChat but it'd be a very
difficult Luddite life because that
happened I think a lot of people
basically gave away this data without
really thinking about it
um so I think we are more privacy
conscious here whereas I don't think
cash is going to go as easily here but
we see it coming here as well where you
choose convenience over tradition or
over Freedom
right yeah but I mean Freddie do you use
cash I mean I I never use cash I try to
keep using cash but it's getting hot
yeah okay for you yeah but I think it is
getting harder so you know in which in
China because it's so easy even in an
informal economy if you're buying fruit
on the street side people they will have
a WeChat code for you to scan you know
if that kind of area is not something
you can use cash in there is really very
few contexts for it anymore well I think
we'll end it there but I hope you get a
red envelope stuffed with dogecoins
at some point in the future probably not
very soon but at some point thank you
very much Cindy
well this week Matt Hancock revealed
that he is going into the celebrity
jungle for I'm a celebrity get me out of
here uh he said that he wants to get in
touch or to show his human side as if we
haven't seen enough of that already I'm
joined here at The Spectator by Stanley
Johnson who has been in the celebrity
jungle in 2017.
um do you think it's a wise move well I
will say I have been there and this is
the first time people have been going
are going back to that jungle I don't
want to give away any Trade Secrets
which is somewhere in Australia and they
haven't been back there since 2017 so
this is you know a historic return yes I
think he is wise I think it's absolutely
fine he's going to have an amazing time
himself and I think his message and he's
been making it clear what his message is
is to speak up for dyslexics and
dyslexia and the battle against
secretary will be heard loud and clear
Matthew could say that it's so much
faster has already been generated that
in the sense he's achieved his objective
even before he's arrived in the jungle
well that's I could see that case he's
had the whip removed do you think that's
unfair
well just speaking totally personally
I'm absolutely delighted that Matt
Hancock has had the whip removed because
I'm fighting very very hard at the
moment a bitter political battle to try
and stop the government proceeding with
a bill I can call it the Reese MOG build
which will effectively scrap 170
environmental regulations and
desperately undermine our position so
one vote less for the government even if
that vote is my account very good news
to my good news to Maya so
I'm absolutely happy about it do you
think that might be we're getting away
from I'm a celebrity here briefly but do
you think that might be why Rishi sunak
uh you turned on going to cop the cop
Summit because he knows he's got this
bill coming up well I think he's a very
very good point I think he's he's going
to have to have to make some huge
gesture in the charmel Sheikh that this
bill was a mistake it's a legacy it's a
legacy Bill if you like it's a legacy
from from from the trust the trust
Administration and
it can be stopped the trouble is he went
through on Rishi unac's very first day
the second reading it can be a straw but
it needs to be stopped and I think if he
makes some signal in that direction and
of course it's not not just cop 26 sorry
27. it's all the international networks
we're in in fact there's another cop
coming up which is the biodiversity cop
which is in Montreal in in December so
yes he has of course he has a good good
record to pronounce them in in
Charleston which is in a sense our
commitment to climate change goes our
commitment to the nature protection goal
which is now in the environment act but
by jove he has to show that he has taken
on board the message which has been
delivered so so severely over the last
few weeks that you know the tourists are
waging a war on nature
scarless journalists are suggesting that
the only reason rishitina is going is
because your son Boris Johnson is going
to the well this is where I think I use
the urkut reply yeah they may say that I
can't possibly comment well in any case
we should probably get back to the to
the Jungle which is meant to be the
point of this conversation
um is it as awful as it looks is it
hellish being there do you did you enjoy
it
at all I didn't think it was hellish at
all and just reverting for a second to
my dyslexia thought for me it was
absolutely wonderful that you couldn't
write you couldn't read they didn't have
the materials but anything else for
writing or reading
you had to talk while thinking about
this election I could imagine this in
many ways an ideal situation for
Matt Hancock says he's had a history of
Dyslexia well he should be in his in his
comfort zone there I found myself in my
comfort zone I can tell you I already
did partly because the people I was with
were so
so fantastic there was a wonderful lady
called Becky vardy you may have been
reading about her in the context of
something called wagatha
could not have been could not have been
nice I did I did a trial trial with Amir
Khan World welterweight boxing champion
couldn't believe he couldn't believe
when I was nominated no elected by nine
million votes of the voters to be the
prime minister of number 10 Downing
Creek
tough who was about 17 years old then
she must be a bit older now was elected
vice president no sorry yes vice versa
vice president prime minister Vice
exactly
and Amir Khan was shocked and horrified
he said but if Stanley has a step aside
we'd have a woman prime minister so we
had to say to him actually I'm here we
have had we have had uh Margaret
Thatcher I don't think we'd had Mrs May
by that point but we definitely had
Margaret Thatcher I mean Matt Hancock
obviously had a rather some Public
Disgrace uh as health secretary uh do
you think the jungle offers people a a
chance to redeem themselves
good Heavens the jungle is redemption
wow well of course there's a good lot of
Catholic you know Catholic what's the
word I'm doing a theology on this isn't
there yeah you know you well they used
to go around hitting themselves and
wasn't there a whole sect of people who
were there were the flagellators they
were cool
that was probably it too yeah yes this
is very interesting I hadn't thought of
that in in terms of its kind of
sacramental sacramental effect I don't
think the public would pretty much Buy
I'd answer that I didn't think they'll
say you know just eating kangaroo
testicles or whatever is is a Penance in
in that sort of sense no I think that
basically he would have to earn his
Redemption if he has to write his room
by being a jolly good performer by doing
the bush Tucker trials and by being
right up there in the front and you
think you'll find that his constituents
at that point will really come over him
in a big way since when did the people
with Suffolk
have a winner of I'm a celebrity get me
out of here but so you the contestants
are the celebrities are asked to do
these Grizzly trials and that's
nominated by the public isn't it so
presumably Hancock with his
woman he is he is going to be in the
firing line that is for sure I can
guarantee the first vote for the public
which the public has they are bound to
say well this one's for math whether
it's going up being hoisted up into the
jungle in the jungle tree with 45 snakes
or whether it's eating some gasoline
something or other or whether it's
swimming underwater and unlocking
various locks in order while their
oxygen is running out yeah no you don't
have oxygen you're having to hold your
breath oh cool well the British public
love torturing people and then forgiving
them so maybe that maybe well maybe I'm
his interesting thought it should be
pursued I would have thought of an
argument of The Spectator on reality tv
as a means of redemption yes would would
do well sacrament of reality TV uh well
yes I think actually one last question
I'm sorry to ask you about your son
again but he recently returned nearly
returned to the other Jungle of sw1 and
Westminster are you relieved on a
paternal level uh that your son will not
be prime minister again no I'm I I'm not
going to go down that route particularly
um because I have learned that there's
no point trying to look ahead and nobody
knows what is going to happen I am
constantly surprised I will say it's
made my life a little bit easier for
example at this very very moment when I
am fiercely opposed to what appears to
be a proposal by the government in the
sense that the government has laid the
bill before Parliament
it makes my life a little bit easier
um to have a conversation like this with
you yes knowing that Morris is not the
man in the you know in the paring line
Stanley Johnson thank you very much for
coming in great pleasure
don't forget to subscribe to The
Spectator
uh our YouTube channel that is do that
by clicking the red button the bottom of
the screen and the bell icon at the top
to get a reminder so that you never ever
miss an episode thank you very much see
you again soon